all right with that ball I dia uh-huh
pop quiz hotshot you know what the bad
moment was my first TV spot oh I was I
was so green that I was just terrible I
was so nervous
it was a show called Friday night videos
and it was my first TV spot and I was so
bad that they didn't even air it and
what was it a what kind of we just stand
up come stand up yeah dude mom was too
they didn't air it really yeah was your
Craig Ferguson they didn't ever good
stuff they had to they didn't they paid
me for it I mean he's paying like at
whatever we don't hurt you when they
didn't do it and her my feelings yeah
wow that would have been devastating why
didn't they said some of the wording or
something the way that I'd said
something I couldn't say it like that I
didn't even know they think they could
do that though you know like Craig lives
right over here
does he really have used to talk to him
since then no you know what I want to
tell Craig did book you on this podcast
yeah yeah tell him he owes me one yeah I
really wouldn't know I really want to do
that tell them there's a guy yeah
program and he's never been he did a set
on your show and it didn't air yeah can
we I wanted to set that out I'd love to
do that that'd be great yeah
because well how long ago was that 10
years yeah but you were so green
probably then yeah but still I mean I've
worked hard and got a good set and I put
it in there
Wow yeah I mean I I've been I've been
cut out of movies have you oh yeah where
you went to a movie theater and you're
watching it you're like well no I'm
still in it
I mean cut completely cut out the whole
thing yeah but you can find him at any
Panda Express guys if you [ __ ] keep
your eyes open you know Wow
well I did not know that about you yeah
yeah what was yours the front net videos
and when it was my first one in air I
just was devastated by it and then um
then years later I did premium blend
yeah and the set was bad and then when I
saw it back
it was bad I didn't like it yeah and
then but then when I walked around a
couple of times you look people
recognized me from it mmm so I thought
it wasn't that bad you know from what
how I imagined it mm-hmm but um early on
man those things are so important yeah
right
[Music]